also what I want to say is a shout-out
to my new buddy I'll tell you my new
buddy Danny Garcia Danny Garcia is a
Mexican kid living at the outside of
Chicago maybe around Chicago he told me
that he was a little chunky Mexican guy
and him and his cousin and his English
friend took me to Osiris this week and I
didn't go to the lighthouse but um I I
got pretty close I got some new gear and
I really appreciate your help in any of
you guys on there are fans of mine
please help me
so you haven't made it to the light how
hard is this like what's the can you
compare it to something cuz I don't mean
oh yeah it's it's it's difficult you
have to go flawless it's basically
you're fighting five rounds per game I
need to win 9 games in a row and you
can't lose one and if you get it's
called flawless and if you get if you do
that then you get to go to the
lighthouse and not a lot of people get
to go but when you go great things
happen so tell us more about your
experience with these and brand new
friends of yours well the English guy
says the n-word a lot harder or softer
really hard our soft end no siree softer
than pronounce Pradhan yeah he's from
England he's from England and he says
the word [ __ ] a lot and I get really
uncomfortable but also he's very good so
I let it go like I want to clear him
like I don't you should say that but I
don't want him to go well I'm not gonna
when I'm not gonna take it to like at
the Lighthouse then so then I go say
whatever you want to say and I giggle
just as long as he can do what he does
you know I don't be conflicted because I
felt conflicted enough to tell me about
it and you're like I don't think that I
can play with these guys anymore
no the Mexican guy like and it's cousin
it's just the English guy he's fine he's
nice but just says things and that's all
you know and a lot of times it's like
you don't have to like you know
Democrats or Republicans they don't have
to get along but the
you know there's a space where they can
meet and that's what I'm meeting him in
space yeah yeah well you smiling
sandy Dan so has this sandy donto has
this really good joke that makes perfect
sense to me where he says it's wrong to
say the word [ __ ] obviously because
it's offensive to a lot of people but
they just the structurally the word
itself is so catchy and so fun to say
yeah it is just such a great structure
dword yeah there's a hard T at the end
hmm it's fun it just rolls off your
tongue well so's the n-word not really
it's fun words not as fun to say I hate
saying it because I don't I don't I
think we're all equal but it's what
there's two G's in the middle two like
[ __ ] yeah but that's oh yeah yeah yeah
what are other words of to geez I don't
know yeah I can't think of top of my
head but um those are two very good
words that you can't say my mom's pet
pig [ __ ] [ __ ]
[Music]